Shure: 那个呢那应该也差不多吧
Shure: How about that one? It should be about ready too, right?
Alice:你可以那个不熟的你再弄回来
Alice: If that one's not done, just put it back.
Alice:啥肉这么碎
Alice: Why is this meat so shredded?
Alice:管他呢，就这吧
Alice:这也放这上面吧
Alice: Let's put this on top too.
Shure: 哦我可以用吉他弹这首歌
Shure: Oh, I can play this song on the guitar.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Shure: 我可以用吉他弹这首歌
Shure: I can play this song on the guitar.
Katrina: 我看着你的脸
Katrina: I'm looking at your face.
Shure: 然后我再给他们送过去
Shure: Then I'll deliver it to them.
Alice:猪
Alice: Pork.
Alice:放冰箱也没事
Alice: It's okay to put it in the fridge.
Alice:有的就专门
Alice: Some are just for...
Alice:嗯放冰箱
Alice: Yeah, put it in the fridge.
Alice:爱你
Alice:感觉明天都是烟味
Alice: I feel like everything will smell like smoke tomorrow.
Alice:感觉这火不旺
Alice: Feels like the fire isn't strong enough.
Alice:炭要碎掉了
Alice: The charcoal is about to crumble.
Alice:爱你
Alice:好香啊好熏啊
Alice: Smells so good, but it's really smoky.
Alice:你避开肉撒
Alice:一点点就行
Alice: Just a little bit is fine.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 为什么不能洒在肉上
Katrina: Why can't we sprinkle it on the meat?
Alice:主要是让那个水掉下去
Alice: The main thing is to let the water fall.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 看看啊试验一下
Katrina: Let's see, let's test it out.
Shure: 这不等你回去吃去吗
Shure: Aren't you waiting to eat when you get back?
Alice:怎么这么生
Alice: Why is it so raw?
Alice:这块肉真好
Alice: This piece of meat is really good.
Katrina: 有一个是我的
Katrina: One of them is mine.
Shure: 就是脑袋里面全只想这一件事了
Shure: You just can't stop thinking about it.
Shure: 就是跟你搜手
Shure: You're obsessed with it.
Lucia: 现在用刮刀刮上了奶油
Lucia: Now spread the cream with a spatula.
Lucia: 要进去看一眼吗
Lucia: Wanna take a look inside?
Shure: 所以边烤着就边吃了
Shure: So we just eat while it bakes.
Shure: 反正菜也好像买少了
Shure: Anyway, it looks like we bought too little food.
Shure: 你看你看你看
Shure: Look, look, look.
Shure: 就这么点啊
Shure: There's just this much.
Shure: 对他就是那个那个那个那个
Shure: Yeah, it's just that, that, that.
Alice:不是我就想让他滴下去
Alice: No, I just wanted it to drip down.
Alice:我嫌火太不旺了
Alice: I think the fire isn't strong enough.
Shure: 嗯在屋里吃的
Shure: Yeah, they were eating inside.
Shure: 不他们在屋里做蛋糕呢
Shure: No, they were making a cake inside.
Shure: 哈哈就是这几个
Shure: Haha, it's just these few.
Shure: 就是这就是为给AI这个数据集就是
Shure: Yeah, this is for giving the AI this dataset.
Shure: 人类在探索一些食物
Shure: Humans are exploring some foods.
Shure: 能不能吃的这种感觉你知道吗
Shure: To see if they are edible, you know?
Shure: 如何把一坨看着还能吃的东西
Shure: How to make something that looks edible...
Alice:我的板呢
Shure: 杨老板回个头
Shure: Jake, turn around.
Alice:我想直接爆炒了
Alice: I want to stir-fry it directly.
Alice:家人说实话
Alice: Honestly, family...
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Shure: 那一瓶才多少
Shure: How much was in that bottle?
Shure: 倒了四五杯
Shure: Poured four or five cups.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: 送里面去吧
Shure: Take it inside.
Alice:都可以
Shure: 来
Shure: Come.
Shure: 这个是能
Shure: This can...
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Katrina: 紧急公关
Katrina: Emergency PR.
Alice:都可以
Alice: It's all good.
Alice:没事
Alice: No problem.
Alice:太慢太慢了
Alice: Too slow, too slow.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Alice:太慢了我感觉这炭火一会就烧完了
Alice: Too slow, I feel like the charcoal will burn out soon.
Shure: 大叔这鸡爪
Shure: Uncle, these chicken feet...
Alice:哎呦哈哈哈哈
Alice: Oh, hahaha.
Alice:我们是不是如果真的要烤的话
Alice:是不是碳应该多点
Alice: Like, the whole thing?
Alice:就整个的
Alice: Just all of it.
Shure: 铺满然后大概而且要要要铺高一点
Shure: Cover it completely and it should be higher too.
Alice:对大概而且要要铺高一点对
Alice: Yeah, cover it completely and make it higher.
Shure: 他离离得感觉有点远是吧
Shure: It feels a bit far, right?
Shure: 是这样的吗
Shure: Is it like this?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 他离得是不是有点远啊
Shure: Isn't it a bit far?
Alice:什么离得有点远
Alice: What's a bit far?
Shure: 这个碳和肉之间的距离的话
Shure: The distance between the charcoal and the meat.
Alice:还行差别不大
Alice: It's fine, not much difference.
Shure: 还还是还行
Shure: It's fine?
Shure: 是吗但反正最起码得铺满它是吧
Shure: Really? But at least it has to be fully covered, right?
Alice:碳也没有很多
Alice:就是
Alice: Exactly.
Shure: 来摆拍一下
Shure: Let's take a staged photo.
Shure: 摆拍一下
Shure: Take a staged photo.
Shure: 好吧其实一直我在干呢
Shure: Okay, actually I've been doing it all along.
Shure: 然后就是给你打打电话
Shure: And then just calling you.
Katrina: 为什么只和你能聊一整夜
Katrina: Why can I talk to you all night?
Shure: 之后就是嗯对是吧
Shure: Then it's like, right?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 为什么才道别就当想见面
Katrina: Why do I want to see you just after saying goodbye?
Shure: 没有没有没有我也在
Shure: No, no, no, I'm here too.
Katrina: 在朋友里面就数你最特特别
Katrina: Among friends, you're the most special.
Katrina: 总让我觉得记忆很甜
Katrina: Always making my memories sweet.
Shure: 你知道我演这个炭演了多久吗
Shure: Do you know how long I've been managing this charcoal?
Katrina: 为什么你在意谁陪我逛街
Katrina: Why do you care who goes shopping with me?
Shure: 引了他妈将近一个小时你知道吗
Shure: Almost a goddamn hour, do you know that?
Alice:才把这个炭整着
Alice: Just got the charcoal fixed.
Shure: 才把这个炭整着
Shure: Just got the charcoal fixed.
Katrina: 为什么你担心谁对我疯癫
Katrina: Why do you worry about who drives me crazy?
Shure: 本来7点多肉就腌好了
Shure: The meat was ready around 7.
Shure: 所以呢啊所以呢
Shure: So what, right?
Katrina: 你说你对我
Katrina: You said you...
Shure: 你现在不还在摸鱼
Shure: Aren't you still slacking off?
Katrina: 多一些却又不说是多那一些
Katrina: More or less, but you won't say how much.
Shure: 那不得摸一会吗
Shure: Can't I slack off for a bit?
Shure: 看我的室友们在干嘛
Shure: Look what my roommates are doing.
Shure: 打个招呼吧
Shure: Say hi.
Katrina: 哈喽
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina: 过两天就可以跟你见面了哈
Katrina: In a few days, we can meet up.
Lucia: 啊啊蛋糕胚
Lucia: Ah, the cake base!
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 你听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure: 我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Shure: 每天都让你模拟大便
Shure: Making you simulate poop every day.
Shure: 好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 时间已经不多
Katrina: Time is running out.
Katrina: 再下去只好只做朋友
Katrina: If this goes on, we can only be friends.
Katrina: 再向前一点点我就会点头
Katrina: If I move forward a little bit, I'll nod my head.
Shure: 分身是吧
Shure: It's a clone, right?
Katrina: 再冲动一点点我就不闪躲
Katrina: If I get a little more impulsive, I won't dodge.
Katrina: 不过三个字
Katrina: Just three words.
Shure: 怎么他小名也叫楠楠
Shure: Why is his nickname also Nan Nan?
Jake:主要是欠了4层的功劳是吧
Jake: Mainly because he owes credit for 4 floors, right?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 他现在就是了
Shure: He is now.
Shure: 我不叫这个了
Shure: I don't call that anymore.
Jake:我也觉得
Jake: I think so too.
Shure: 那你叫什么
Shure: Then what do you call?
Shure: 叫北北是吗
Shure: Beibei, right?
Shure: 大草莓
Shure: Big strawberry.
Lucia: 我自己觉得超好吃
Lucia: I think it's super delicious.
Shure: 嗯他是黄
Shure: Hmm, it's yellow.
Jake:嗯奶油好吃
Jake: Hmm, the cream is delicious.
Shure: 不是他是黄油
Shure: No, it's butter.
Lucia: 谢谢老师夸奖哈哈哈
Lucia: Thanks for the compliment, teacher, hahaha.
Katrina: 为什么我的过去很容易安慰我们
Katrina: Why is my past so easy to comfort us?
Shure: 他是奶油
Shure: It's cream.
Shure: 跟咱俩那天买的那个是一样的
Shure: Just like the one we bought that day.
Katrina: 心里面明明都有感觉
Katrina: We both feel it in our hearts.
Alice:熟了吗
Alice: Is it cooked?
Lucia: 咱俩是不是得给老师点精神损失费啊
Lucia: Should we give the teacher some mental compensation?
Lucia: 你说哈哈哈哈
Lucia: You say, hahaha.
Shure: 就是那个带黄油味的那个
Shure: It's the one with the butter flavor.
Katrina: 为什么不分辨
Katrina: Why not distinguish?
Jake:老师我给你烤肉去好吧
Jake: Teacher, I'll grill some meat for you, okay?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 为什么你寂寞只想要我陪
Katrina: Why do you only want me to accompany you when you're lonely?
Shure: 那个奶油
Shure: That cream.
Shure: 不是啊那个奶油是个海盐的吧
Shure: No, isn't that cream salted?
Jake:老师你要吃什么肉
Jake: Teacher, what kind of meat do you want?
Lucia: 儿子你要吃什么肉
Lucia: Son, what kind of meat do you want?
Katrina: 为什么我难过只肯让你安慰
Katrina: Why do I only let you comfort me when I'm sad?
Shure: 啊对海盐的那个
Shure: Ah, yes, the salted one.
Katrina: 我们心里面明明都有感觉
Katrina: We both clearly have feelings inside.
Alice:好像瘦了吧
Alice: Seems like you've lost weight, right?
Katrina: 为什么不敢面对
Katrina: Why don't we dare to face it?
Shure: 沉浸式给你表演吃饭
Shure: Let me give you an immersive eating performance.
Katrina: 友达以上恋人未满
Katrina: More than friends, less than lovers.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 甜蜜心酸愉悦混乱
Katrina: Sweet, sour, joyful, and chaotic.
Katrina: 我们以后会变怎样
Katrina: What will become of us in the future?
Katrina: 我迫不及待想知道答案
Katrina: I'm eager to know the answer.
Shure: 认识四年了头一回打视频是吧
Shure: We've known each other for four years and this is the first time we're video chatting, right?
Katrina: 再靠近一点就让你牵手
Katrina: If we get a little closer, I'll let you hold my hand.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈不是吧差不多
Shure: Hahaha, almost, right?
Katrina: 再勇敢一点点我就跟你走
Katrina: If I get a bit braver, I'll go with you.
Shure: 只不过上次跟你打视频的时候
Shure: Just last time when we were video chatting...
Katrina: 你还等什么时间已经不多
Katrina: What are you waiting for? Time is running out.
Shure: 我也在跟我群友打视频而已啦嗯
Shure: I was just video chatting with my group mates, that's all.
Katrina: 再下去只好只做朋友
Katrina: If this keeps up, we'll only be friends.
Katrina: 再向前一点点我就会点头
Katrina: If you move a bit forward, I'll nod my head.
Alice:虾仁盘子可以拿过来了
Alice: You can bring over the shrimp plate now.
Shure: 大一的时候都没打过是吧
Shure: We didn't video chat during freshman year, right?
Lucia: 是不是要再打一些
Lucia: Should we make some more?
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Shure: 以后不要不要羞涩跟你讲
Shure: From now on, don't be shy when talking to you.
Shure: 不要像现在那么不要脸
Shure: Don't be as shameless as you are now.
Shure: 哈哈哈啊
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:应该都熟了
Alice: It should be cooked by now.
Shure: 你是在说你自己吗
Shure: Are you talking about yourself?
Shure: 是的那不然呢
Shure: Yes, who else?
Alice:把它们叫出来
Alice: Bring them out.
Alice:可以吃了
Alice: They're ready to eat.
Shure: 真好意思真好意思
Shure: How considerate, how considerate.
Alice:每个人分一点点吧
Alice: Everyone can have a little bit.
Shure: 真羞涩那
Shure: So shy, huh.
Shure: 时候怎么了
Shure: What happened back then?
Shure: 那时候不羞涩吗
Shure: Weren't you shy back then?
Shure: 你不要做那青蛙表情
Shure: Don't make that frog face.
Katrina: 尝两口然后端进去
Katrina: Taste a bit and then take it in.
Katrina: 你已经在吃蛋糕了
Katrina: You're already eating the cake.
Shure: 你可以把它剪一下吗
Shure: Can you cut it up?
Shure: 就是把这个大的剪刀剪
Shure: Just use these big scissors to cut it.
Katrina: 剪刀在哪呀
Katrina: Where are the scissors?
Shure: 那不用的了
Shure: Nevermind, don't need them.
Katrina: 这要洗一下不
Katrina: Does this need washing?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Exactly.
Shure: 是一直捡手肉的
Shure: I always pick up the meat by hand.
Shure: 我帮你我帮你夹一下来
Shure: Let me help you, I'll hold it for you.
Lucia: 哦那是那个生蚝他们还没烤呢
Lucia: Oh, those oysters aren't grilled yet.
Shure: 他其实应该再剪碎一点
Shure: It should be cut into smaller pieces.
Katrina: 还要剪碎一点
Katrina: Cut it smaller?
Shure: 你哎没事挺好挺好
Shure: No worries, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 嗯准备出去了吗
Lucia: Are you ready to go out?
Shure: 这个这个再见
Shure: This, this, goodbye.
Alice:哒哒哒哒
Alice: Da da da da.
Katrina: 呀呀
Katrina: Ah ah.
Shure: 你从你先从底下剪然后这样
Shure: Start cutting from the bottom, then like this.
Lucia: 灯怎么灭了
Lucia: Why did the light go out?
Shure: 我不就一可以一直可以夹着吗
Shure: I can just keep holding it, right?
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 学费了吗
Shure: Have you paid the tuition?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:你们可以先吃一点点
Alice: You can have a little bit first.
Shure: 你在看什么
Shure: What are you looking at?
Alice:在那个盘里
Alice: In that dish.
Alice:我夹过去了
Alice: I put it there.
Alice:杨老板你是不是饿了
Alice: Jake, are you hungry?
Katrina: 没有直接上筷子吧
Katrina: Let's just use the chopsticks directly.
Alice:怎么这么多筷子呀
Alice: Why are there so many chopsticks?
Alice:咦这怎么有蛋糕啊
Alice: Eh, why is there cake here?
Shure: 忘跟大叔说了
Shure: Forgot to tell the uncle.
Alice:谢谢尝一块
Alice: Thanks, I'll try a piece.
Shure: 开早开早
Shure: Early start, early start.
Shure: 我感觉这个比刚刚那个味味好了一些
Shure: I think this tastes better than the previous one.
Alice:你腌的时间长吗
Alice: Did you marinate it for a long time?
Alice:关这咋吃
Alice: How do we eat this?
Alice:这咋吃啊
Alice:这是不是有孜然啊
Alice: Does this have cumin?
Shure: 真的我觉得应该跟你在这看色之前
Shure: Honestly, I think I should have seen this before.
Alice:有芝麻不给我
Alice: There's sesame but you didn't give me any.
Katrina: 孜然粉就是在里面
Katrina: The cumin powder is in there.
Shure: 每天远程当我的数据集
Shure: I use it daily for my data set.
Shure: 那天
Shure: That day...
Alice:那个是啥呀
Alice:那个
Alice:哎呀好东西
Alice: Wow, this is good stuff.
Alice:生着
Alice:那筷子是生的
Alice:就那啊
Alice: Just that, right?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yep.
Alice:没事我不吃蛋糕太甜了
Alice: It's okay, I don't eat cake. It's too sweet.
Alice:看里面还是生的
Alice: Look, it's still raw inside.
Alice:有点汁水
Alice: There's a bit of juice.
Alice:不过还好
Alice: But it's fine.
Alice:再过一会就能吃了
Alice: A bit more time and it will be ready.
Katrina: 你饿不
Katrina: Are you hungry?
Alice:一闻哪饭味儿就
Alice: As soon as I smell the food...
Alice:喜欢撒芝麻的过程
Alice: I like the process of sprinkling sesame.
Alice:看看它会不会掉下去
Alice: Let's see if it falls off.
Alice:老板这锅快好了
Alice: Boss, this pot is almost ready.
Jake:可以啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, haha.
Alice:多了吗杨老板
Alice: Is it too much, Jake?
Jake:期待期待
Jake: Looking forward to it.
Alice:给你也尝一个
Alice: Try one too.
Jake:只是期待
Jake: Just looking forward to it.
Alice:有点烫啊
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Alice:你把那个碳给翻个个吧
Alice: Flip that piece of charcoal over.
Alice:恩
Alice:不过感觉快烧完了差不多
Alice: But it feels like it's almost burnt out.
Jake:呃好我来切
Jake: Okay, I'll cut it.
Alice:哎我的夹呢
Alice:没事，等一下
Alice:麻烦
Alice:给我吧
Alice:给我吧我现在强的可怕
Alice: Give it to me, I'm super strong now.
Alice:拿盘子吧
Alice: Get a plate.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Alice:咋每次都是新盘子
Alice: Why is it always a new plate?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Alice:你们都刷了
Alice: Did you wash them all?
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha: 哦这个记得不错谢谢
Tasha: Oh, this is pretty good, thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:我先把盘子送出去
Jake: I'll take the plates out first.
Alice:什么意思啊
Alice: What do you mean?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Alice:吓死我了
Alice: That scared me to death.
Alice:我年纪轻轻不会做出母爱的味道了吧
Alice: I'm too young to have a motherly touch, right?
Alice:可以来认领鸡翅了
Alice: You can come claim the chicken wings now.
Alice:你把他们叫出来吧
Alice: You should call them out.
Alice:我感觉这会火挺好的
Alice: I think this will be quite popular.
Lucia: 我们那边蛋糕马上就好了
Lucia: Our cake is almost ready.
Lucia: 已经进行到最后一步了
Lucia: We're in the final step.
Alice:鸡翅好啦
Alice: The chicken wings are done.
Jake:炮台啊这是
Jake: It's like a cannon.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah, ah.
Lucia: 咱草莓不够啊
Lucia: We're short on strawberries.
Alice:要不要尝一个
Alice: Want to try one?
Alice:排骨
Alice: Ribs.
Alice:应该
Alice: Should be.
Alice:差不多
Alice: Almost.
Alice:这个会嫩一点
Alice: This one will be a bit more tender.
Alice:你喜欢吃嫩就夹这个
Alice: If you like tender, take this one.
Alice:把这个也给你
Alice: I'll give you this one too.
Alice:搁上去就这样
Alice:这个是滋滋冒油版
Alice: This one's the sizzling oily version.
Alice:尝一个
Alice:那个盆
Alice: That bowl.
Alice:哎没有没有
Alice: Oh, no, no.
Alice:我说那个
Alice: I mean that one.
Alice:那个腌肉的盆在哪在这
Alice: Where's the bowl for marinating meat? Here it is.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:这俩料一样吧
Alice: These two seasonings are the same, right?
Alice:鸡翅好了
Alice: Chicken wings are done.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:每人拿一个吧
Alice: Everyone take one.
Alice:嗯倒了吗
Alice: Hmm, did you pour it?
Jake:来啊就倒着是吧
Jake: Yeah, just pour it, right?
Tasha: 啦
Tasha: La.
Alice:啊就是让那样亮一点的
Alice: Ah, just to make it brighter.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:啊就更近一点是吧
Jake: Ah, a bit closer, right?
Alice:YES
Alice:哎呀
Alice:盘子有吗
Alice: Do we have plates?
Alice:我靠我要是退休真潇洒就好了
Alice: Man, if I could retire, that would be awesome.
Alice:我的板呢
Alice: Where's my board?
Alice:盘子我觉得趁热吃好吃
Alice: I think the plate is better when it's hot.
Alice:来盘吧
Alice: Let's get a plate.
Alice:哎哟没关系，就这样
Alice:你离我近一点
Alice:你们趁热吃吧
Alice:嗯闻着饭味我就有点不好了
Jake:我来烤会
Jake: I'll grill for a bit.
Jake:我帮你一会
Jake: I'll help you in a bit.
Jake:那得用啊
Jake: You need to use it.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:排骨搁外面
Jake:这个碳是弄碎了吗
Jake: Is this charcoal crushed?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:来吃一个
Jake: Have a bite.
Tasha: 来吃一个
Tasha: Have a bite.
Tasha: 吃个什么呢
Tasha: What should we eat?
Jake:吃个什么呢我去
Jake: What should we eat, oh man.
Tasha: 我去
Tasha: Oh man.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.